دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ  *** بِصُبْحَةِ مَامَا رَاحَ السُّوقْ
مَامَا سَتَبْتَاعُ لَهُ الحَلْوَى  ***  وسَيَّارَةْ بِمِقْوَدِهَا بُوقْ
دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ
دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ  *** بِصُبْحَةِ مَامَا رَاحَ السُّوقْ
مَامَا سَتَبْتَاعُ لَهُ الحَلْوَى  ***  وسَيَّارَةْ بِمِقْوَدِهَا بُوقْ
دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ
لَكِنْ دُقْدُقْ ذَاكَ شَقِي
قَدْ أَزْعَجَ كَلْبَ الحِرَفِيْ
طَارَدَهُ فَانْقَلَبَ المَتْجَرْ  ***  واحْتَاجَ لِعِوَضٍ فَوْرِيْ
دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ
سَحَبَ كَذَلِكَ سَلَّةَ بَيْضْ
فَتَنَاثَرَ سَقَطَ عَلَى الأَرْضْ
قَالَتْ مَامَا مَا تُفْسِدُهُ  *** لِأُصْلِحَهُ أَحْتَاجُ لِقَرْضْ
دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ
دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ  *** بِصُبْحَةِ مَامَا رَاحَ السُّوقْ
مَامَا سَتَبْتَاعُ لَهُ الحَلْوَى  ***  وسَيَّارَةْ بِمِقْوَدِهَا بُوقْ
دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ
ذَهَبَا لِمَحِّلِّ الأَلْعَابْ ***   بِالرُدْهَةِ يَجْرِي دَقْدُوقْ
كَسَرَ مِنَ العَجَلَةْ الدُّولابْ ***    وَتَحَطَّمَ أَيْضًا صُنْدُوقْ
دَفَعَتْ مَامَا لِتُعَوِّضَهُ
لَمْ يَبْقَ لَهَا مَا تُنْفِقَهُ
قَالَتْ هَيَّا نَذْهَبْ دُقْدُقْ ***    لَكِنْ هَذَا لَمْ يُعْجِبْهُ
دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ دُقْدُقْ يَا دَقْدُوقْ
وَبَكَى دُقْدُقْ أَيْنَ الْلُعْبَةْ
قَالَتْ مَامَا لَنْ نَجْلِبَهَا
لَا نَمْلِكُ مَالاً يَكْفِيهَا ***     بِشَقَاوَتِكَ لَنْ تَمْلُكْهَا
بِشَقَاوَتِكَ لَنْ تَمْلُكْهَا
دُقْدُقْ دقدق يا دقدوق ***      عَادَ إِلَى البَيْتِ مِنَ السُوقْ
يَشْعُرُ بِالنَدَمِ لِأَفْعَالِهْ  ***   أَيْنَ السَّيارَةَ والبُوقْ
أَيْنَ السَّيارَةَ والبُوقْ